hey what's going on let's go
it's bill bird it's time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday February
13th 2017 what's going on how are ya huh
y'all how you doing over there
why is it why is Friday the 13th
unlucky in Monday the 13th oh that's
just [ __ ] fine you know it was a [ __ ]
who came up with that one you think
Monday the 13th [ __ ] yeah unlucky 13 and
it's Monday and I got five [ __ ] days
in front of me I have to work Friday
thirteen who gives a [ __ ] you stub your
toe a couple of times and next thing you
know you're at the TGI Fridays right you
down there eyeball in one of the way you
know you come up to it you tell her you
like her striped shirt start bitching
about the horrible day you had you know
she's a woman so she'll listen to it
she'll kick into that motherly instinct
unless she already has kids and then she
doesn't have time for it you know then
she looks in she says listen I made
sucking your dick alright did you get
the [ __ ] out of here and then you move
on to something yoga is that how it goes
why what is so [ __ ] unlucky you know
what I didn't even know I was gonna die
gonna look to something why is Friday
the 13th unlucky hang on us then we get
pause for a second all right before I
can't just looked it up I didn't read
any I just got I just got to the Google
thing where they got whatever it is on
the first page all right whose kid knew
with the internet whatever the fact is
the fact is whatever you look up within
the first two [ __ ] clicks on the
first page becomes the truth that's it
okay so that's what the [ __ ] I'm looking
at you know if the right answer to any
question is [ __ ] beyond what you have
to scroll down the first page of any
subject on of the Internet it's it's
over no one's ever gonna know the truth
because of who who the [ __ ] ever goes to
page 14 not even journalists do that
they don't give a [ __ ] all right I'm
gonna say either has to do with it's got
to be religious
it's got to be religious Jesus did
something he always had bad Friday's
didn't he
no he had a good Friday good today is
Good Friday what happened on Good Friday
then he did the rock roll back and he
came walking out you know like one of
those [ __ ] movies where they thought
they killed the guy and he didn't and
then he comes back except not like Tom
Sawyer [ __ ] creep hanging out of his
own funeral I was done with that kid
once he did that she'll say this kids a
[ __ ] weirdo
all right Friday 13th why is it unlucky
and other facts about the worst day in
the calendar in the calendar not on the
calendar we're in it we're not in it
we're not on it alright finally 13th
considered by many as one of the
unluckiest days of the year is almost
here again this is from January 2017 oh
[ __ ] January 13th well [ __ ] nothing
happen to us if you're still alive if
you're worried about what's in store
Baba bah bah bah bah bah bah bah bah
what the [ __ ] in 2000 here's some of the
fun facts when is the next Friday 13th
know why stupid
all right biblical orange origins all
right of course it always goes back to
the Bible
oh Jesus dad's mad [ __ ] mode he had a
bad week you know of course it's the
kids fault
stupid [ __ ] he tried to build everything
in six [ __ ] days typical
do-it-yourself job why didn't you farm
it out to someone who knew what the [ __ ]
they were doing built the thing up to
code you dope [ __ ] sticking a steel
beam in the middle of a [ __ ] wood
wall yeah everything above it is
supported better what about below it dad
what about the law the [ __ ] did this
music come from
alright let's read with this music on in
the background
the superstition about this day is
thought to have I can't do this thing
stop to have come about all right that's
enough of that during the Middle Ages
and many have biblical origins some
historians have claimed it was the day
on which Eve bit the Apple from the tree
of knowledge ease ascribed the [ __ ] out
of me near the lovely near everybody Oh
with my beautiful daughter two lovely
ladies what's going on
now it's watching the videos that people
sent me this week what's going on are
you gonna drop her off no I can't do the
podcast the way I talk that's why I was
in here with the door closed
it's a pocket door by the way if you
wonder why just squeak like we live in a
haunted house no I just found another I
just saw another place that I I want to
show you that maybe you wanted to order
from yeah just order me something
remotely healthy something to stave off
the calories I consumed an alcohol a
bowl with rice and tofu and that sir I
hate tofu it's got to be a real dead
animal of vegetables okay so you want
you want meat so I shouldn't order from
a vegan place then I like vegan as long
as there's none of that tofu and I don't
understand what that stuff is it's like
the type of [ __ ] that they seal caps
with so yeah so liquid doesn't be good
it's not good for you no tofu doesn't
come from a tree does it
there's no tofu trees yeah but isn't so
bad for you no I have no weight don't
get your phone for you I don't know just
if you're gonna order from a vegan place
just get me vegetables [ __ ] that I you
know I know what I know what it is I
don't know what tofu is it's like
[ __ ] algae or something
all right shuffles Nia do you know why
Friday the 13th is unlucky I don't know
either I've been reading about here the
new and then they started to say that
Eve [ __ ] maybe bit the Apple they
were in paradise there was no calendar
what do they have to
worried about its no bills they have to
go to work you know what are they doing
and it [ __ ] II love [ __ ] it Monday
same [ __ ] different day it's [ __ ]
paradise
I don't understand wife it was paradise
why they had a [ __ ] snake in there
trying to [ __ ] everything up yeah but
that's on God they're not to say if God
made everything he also made he also
made the [ __ ] of all [ __ ] did he not so
the devil was basically a bad hire that
came back and tried to take his company
down all right
okay let me finish reading this okay in
the New Testament I love how they blame
the woman that that's why everything's
all [ __ ] up I mean without a doubt if
you told a broad did not go over there
and eat the [ __ ] Apple she's gonna be
intrigued you know like a guy wouldn't
whatever you did that's the classic
thing like a substitute teaching
whatever you do don't laugh next person
who laughs gets detention that's it
you're done you [ __ ] squeezing your
nose doing that [ __ ] little kid
laughs that's it Nick see no you're
missing a week of research recess that's
why you got all these fat [ __ ] kids
the regular teacher takes the day off
the substitute teacher creates the
tension though the one skinny kid starts
laughing and then he's done he's eating
that [ __ ] food down the cafeteria
that's got all the preservatives in it
do you know if you [ __ ] kill somebody
in and nobody figures it out you're not
in the clear for a good forty years
that's how legging people up from 12
years ago and then that's like they took
a [ __ ] nap hey I'll tell you these
people they're full of preservatives you
know all right and the New Testament
there were thirteen people present for
Jesus Jesus's Last Supper on Maundy
Thursday Mon da MMA und why is that some
other [ __ ] day of the week they used
to have I mean the New Testament that
wasn't in the Old Testament oh wait a
minute we [ __ ] up thought there was 12
to 13 the day before crisis crucifixion
on Good Friday
oh good friday say went out he had a
couple of beers he had a good [ __ ]
time and the next thing you know he got
the old right there Fred all right more
bad luck
on Friday October 13th 1307 Philip the
fourth of France shouldn't be a Phillipe
le cat arrested hundreds of of the
Knights Templar and is well what the for
what did they do
then his novel Da Vinci Code dan Brown
cites the 14th century execution oh who
gives a [ __ ] you know what I mean
you know something it's just all
[ __ ] that's what it is you always
know it was I'm trying to think of
anything Bad's ever happening on the
13th but I pay off phantom if you get
bad luck today [ __ ] old ladies
keeping that [ __ ] going that's what it
is oh by the way a really good friend of
mine and one of the [ __ ] best
comedians I've ever seen Nick DiPaolo
the great Nick DiPaolo he has a new
stand-up special a new one our stand-up
special that's debuting this Thursday
February 16th at 8:00 8:00 p.m. on seeso
TV called inflammatory I don't get to
watch him as much since I'm out here and
but he is somebody the last time I
worked with them was that comics come
home once again legendary set and that's
it he's just one of those [ __ ] guys
he's just he's the guy he's the [ __ ] and
he's got a new special on see self check
it out
Thursday Friday after Thursday February
16th at 8 p.m. it's called inflammatory
and he also used to host a show with
Artie Lange and now he's doing his own
podcast to subscribe to his podcast you
can go to connect pal co NN ECT pal
dot-com slash Nick all right there we go
so do you know what you know what the
[ __ ] I did today you know what my dumb
ass did
inside getting on the elliptical which
was a good thing all right I took my
life insurance [ __ ] test this guy had
a problem hitting my vein he goes she
gonna bruise a little bit you should see
me I look like I don't look like I've
been doing smack I just look like
somebody just pinched my [ __ ] inside
of my elbow really [ __ ] hard anyway
so I did all that what a [ __ ] show that
was [ __ ] guys sitting there going do
you drink it all right and like wait
he's got his back to my bar which I told
you is murderers row the bottles I have
there I told you right now I'd put it up
against the 27 Yankees the 96 Bulls
let's go some underrated teams the 83-76
somehow lost in history about how
[ __ ] great they were right the 86
Celtics the 85 Lakers the [ __ ] 2016
new england patriots the 98 yankees that
was a great team for the [ __ ] free
agent their way i mean speaking of what
you know that red sox are doing that
this year it's a good year to get the
package no matter what you're gonna be
entertained you either get to watch like
a [ __ ] 900 million dollar team [ __ ]
the bed or just you know there is no
Santa Claus we're buying it one of the
other either way it's gonna be dramatic
so anyways I got a such a funny question
I meet drinks tea I don't [ __ ] know
do I have a pocket protector I don't
count them like you know they always
think you know it's funny they [ __ ]
say having a glass of wine with your
meal is actually good for you you know
what I mean so I mean I don't I don't
understand that do you smoke yeah it's
[ __ ] lying your ass off no Jesus I
would can you imagine if you'd imagine
anybody even the [ __ ] people who work
there if you answered any of those
questions [ __ ] honestly you know what
I mean alright Bruin and I probably
shouldn't be talking about this who
gives a [ __ ] there's a comedy podcast
these are all jokes everybody this is
what I did today my [ __ ] dumb ass did
today so
you know I'm gonna be the person
presenter at the Writers Guild know the
the yeah the Writers Guild Awards thing
right and so they say it's a black-tie
thing and I'm like ah [ __ ] I got to get
a [ __ ] tuxedo so I call up by time I
call up it's too late to get one
Sonia Google's some pictures and
everybody seems like relaxed like
they're just wearing suits with the
black tie so I say [ __ ] it I wear one of
my suit so I pull out a suit I get the
shirt we do the whole [ __ ] thing I
got it to go and all that so today I'm
dressing up you know I'm hanging with my
daughter I'm putting my time in you know
cuz I'm gonna be gone for three four
hours and Nia's gonna be handling by
herself then I'm gonna go out and go do
this this [ __ ] Hollywood thing right
and and I'm sitting there and I know do
you know the red carpet and everything's
between three or four and I'm like I
can't I don't know when the [ __ ] the
cars coming to pick me up I'm all
dressed up ready to go you know two
o'clock 205 210 215 I'm texting people
hey when's his car coming to get me 225
I walk outside I'm looking around I
don't see anybody I'm just sitting there
and it finally dawns on me I'm like wait
a minute and I just looked up the date
of the [ __ ] award show it's next
Sunday that hilarious you know the funny
thing about is his Mia got mad at me why
did you write things down Oh get up it's
not I didn't miss it I just was a little
early and now I know you know I know
that you know I know what I'm gonna wear
now I'm actually way ahead of the game
cuz I cuz I [ __ ] up what'd he want
from me anyway speaking of this is
something I gotta let you guys know
about the the Patrice O'Neal comedy
benefit the fifth annual Patrice O'Neal
comedy event benefit we're actually
going to be releasing some some tickets
some high-quality tickets I guess you
say some really good seats and we're
gonna be doing that Monday today if you
listen to it on Monday Jesus Christ with
the [ __ ] open under the door there
that's why what is ridiculous how am i
thrashing you come here come on kitty
i'm coming they're coming at coming in
don't yell don't yell you got the kid
there what it's absolutely absurd for
you to not know when things are anymore
it's like you're a grown-ass man and
you've got all dressed to go why is it
always grown-ass why can't you say
you're grown up I can say whatever I
want to say and I'm not choosing to say
that you're a grown-ass man who can't
seem to write anything is that because
you're a strong woman to the point where
you gonna get all dressed up and be like
what am I gonna wear
there's none the other and then you come
downstairs five minutes later like well
it's next week you need to get it
together it's not cute yeah that's like
the first thing I've screwed up like
that a long time I have a bunch of
events in my phone right in a calendar
section we're getting when things are
you're always getting the dates wrong
and it's frustrating it's just annoying
all right but how am i doing is it dad
what's have to do with anything you're
doing amazingly as it all right what
stop acting like I'm in some shooting at
Rouen in an alley alley but you just
need I just don't understand why you
can't ever get your schedule straight
euro peace getting the dates wrong like
oh it's tomorrow not today it's next
week not this week like I don't have to
get it yeah I'm busy and I don't have an
assistant you will you should get an
assist I don't want another person to
talk to okay
I would tell you to get an assistant for
like three years now because of this
very reason yeah you want to hear all
the [ __ ] I did this week that I made
totally got there on time no you don't
okay you know why because that would
prove my point if I was a baseball what
is your point exactly
99% of [ __ ] I get there on time 99% of
knowing you did get mad at me I'm not
well then what's the problem why do you
have to drat eclis open her squeaky
pocket door to come in here and shirt
yourself on the podcast
alright are you done are you kicking me
out now are you almost done no I've just
started you just well people send me I
know I'm 17 minutes in oh Jesus I came
up here to watch the Grammys but I can't
turn the TV on now right it'll watch the
Grammys okay I'm going to is it gonna be
a bunch of people like write new verses
about how Trump's the most evil thing
ever
there's some chick that showed up on the
red carpet wearing a sparkly dress that
said make America great again and then
Trump on the back of it I don't know who
she is
but everyone's already like what oh my
god she's like just for somebody to show
up at a Hollywood event like that in a
dress that says like you know it's
pro-trump is pretty pretty
paint-by-numbers shucks I guess do you
think she'll get some free press out of
that I think she will was she wearing
Madonna's beret no she was not I'm going
to a protest what should I wear a pro
Trump dress I know I know because that
other [ __ ] is played out acting like the
sky is falling so now they're gonna go
the other direction yeah I know but I
feel like that's not gonna be like good
press for her you know I hate oats any
any press is good press that's how this
dirty town works yeah I guess so well
you could just put out a good album
right and not rely on your stupid
clothes yeah if you put out a good album
you can keep your clothes on you don't
have to say who you voted for you can
just go up there and accept your shiny
thing that's true all right I'm gonna
take the baby okay buh-bye anyways
alright quote if you pull the door lower
it doesn't squeak as much see there you
go see that no you almost did it
you can watch the Grammys near go ahead
anyways oh by the way I'm gonna
[ __ ] this up the two [ __ ] best
channels right now in my in my not
humble opinion many people say in my
humble opinion like you're a humble
person you're not you're injecting your
[ __ ] ideas most likely into a
conversation that you just overheard or
is that just me in my opinion I don't
when the humble came about you know hey
you know I'm boo am I Who am I who are
you you're the [ __ ] guy that is is
you know holding court right now with
your opinions there's nothing [ __ ]
humble about this you shining a
spotlight on yourself you know I'm
actually in a good mood too
hang on a second let me let me [ __ ]
find this stuff there's two [ __ ]
channels out there vice land is the [ __ ]
I already told you about that
and now what's-his-face puffy has a new
network Puffy's you can't Puffy's
network they said Net Worth revolt it's
another great [ __ ] channel both of
those channels remind me of the early
days of MTV the early days of MTV was
somewhere between obviously regular
television and then just basic cable
[ __ ] lunatics which I really miss how
everybody used to watch this guy
Damon's ex talked about this a long time
ago in the Opie and Anthony show he's
the pretend he was running for office
Damon Zechs there it is there it is this
guy was a [ __ ] superstar I think was
channel 8 there he is
I love this [ __ ] guy
oh this is this isn't gonna translate
well da mo n ze ex and he used to do
this thing when you pretend that he was
running for office this crazy makeup on
and just saying all this [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and me and Bobby Kelly we're living
together when Stone sober we would just
watch that guy like late night after we
did our spots just ordered Chinese food
and would just sit there watching the
guy laughing our asses off and [ __ ]
getting freaked out I don't know but the
early days of MTV was like that and I
haven't seen you know network television
or basic cable be like that in a long
time and I gotta tell you those two
[ __ ] channels just great a bunch of
random [ __ ] in there original shows
I don't know Puffy's channels more like
I just sat there watching it and was
that guy what the [ __ ] his name not
Mike Jones guys really kill her Mike
kill him Mike and I guess the guy he
raps with is white I don't know anything
about but they [ __ ] just filmed him
they just sat around talking about their
albums one guy smoking weed he has like
a [ __ ] coughing fit for like 30
seconds they don't even edit it out I
don't happens just sitting in I'm like
two hours into this thing gonna [ __ ] him
I still watching this but it's way more
interesting than a lot I don't I like it
check it out if you feel like it you
like it whatever what are you gonna do
anyways alright let's let's talk about
the world of sports as I always do as I
eventually do as I always make my way
back to the old bread and circus here
Bruce Cassidy new coach of the Boston
Bruins former player came up with the
Blackhawks in like the 80s and
unfortunately had like three or four
knee injuries this is all I know about
the guy and then he paid his [ __ ]
dues as a coach coming up my favorite
will stop that he had on the way up he
coached for the Jacksonville lizard
Kings which you know I'm throwing and
I'm throwing my vote and that's one of
the best that's one of the best [ __ ]
names for a minor-league team huh the
Liz
Kings it's a reference to the doors they
got a bunch of reptiles in Florida and
[ __ ] Jim Morrison got arrested in
Florida for allegedly taking his dick
out also known in some circles as you
lizard and who doesn't want to be a king
you know if you got the Sacramento Kings
you got the LA Kings and he got the
Jacksonville lizard Kings um anyways
he's undefeated so far you know granted
you know we were playing our best hockey
I felt of the season when I when he took
over but uh this is a new guy you know I
got a support there what's his face
posture knock with the [ __ ] uh with
the game-winner against the Vancouver
Canucks after he made a very sketchy
pass in the first period he makes it up
[ __ ] unbelievable came down the
[ __ ] left side slammed on the brakes
just like I do
it picked up hockey except he actually
stopped rather than continuing into the
boards and hurting himself and then
[ __ ] little whatever the [ __ ] he did
he put it in it was fantastic oh it was
tremendous but I got to tell you guys
about the greatest sporting event I
think I've been to since I went to the
New England Patriots first Los Angeles
Rams when we won our first Super Bowl
and all I can tell you about Duke at
Cameron Indoor Arena it's like how loud
the crowd was when Vinatieri kicked that
field goal it was that loud the whole
[ __ ] game I've never been to anything
like it and we sat in the low we were
sitting center court I thought we're
gonna be behind the bench sorry about
that we would center court not on the
student site across from them in the
lower area and dude I'll tell you
there's no [ __ ] way to get out of
there there's no way to go to the
bathroom
there's no way to [ __ ] there's nobody
coming around to concessions you have
[ __ ] you are in there and that is it
old school [ __ ] barn you went in it's
so small I guess it holds like 9,000
people but you
felt like you were in there with like
200 people and we came in and it was
already they were already shooting
around before the game and we finally
got to our seats like you just don't
think that your seats are even gonna be
there because everybody's so jammed in
and we didn't sit down for the whole
[ __ ] game I guess I started sitting
down during timeouts because I'm old and
I got to tell you I've never I've never
seen an atmosphere like that ever this
beats everything I've been to the NCAA
the championship game was in the [ __ ]
Georgia Dome so I mean that's a shitty
place to want your basketball game even
people going nuts it just floats up to
the top of the the the the dome and you
don't even hear it
I'm just like I don't even know what I
didn't know where to begin and then it
was an unbelievable game just back and
forth back and forth when it looked like
UNC was gonna pull away Duke would come
back then it look like Duke was gonna
have the game on ice and then you went
si would come back somebody hit a three
someone else would hit a [ __ ] three
was unbelievable and I was very
impressed with both teams I liked that
kid on UNC number 44
he doesn't rattle he doesn't [ __ ] act
like he changed the game of basketball
when he hits a shot all he gave a [ __ ]
about was winning he hit some big
three-pointer and then they immediately
called time out rather than thumping his
own chest and acting like he's in
Braveheart he came back to the bench
high five but you see he was pissed
because they just had just let up an
easy bucket before he hit his three and
I don't know I don't know [ __ ] about
anything but if I was a scout I would
pay attention to that just as much as
somebody actually doing great things out
on the court and it was insane dude
[ __ ] Coach K coming out I just I
reminded me when I won that why I went
to the Kings game when they wrapped it
up one time to win a Stanley Cup and I
saw them bring the Stanley Cup out it
was like that except it could walk
around talking so I want to thank I want
to thank Mike all at the comedy zone in
Charlotte the two awesome shows and
thank you so much for getting us in
touch with the person that hooked us up
with the tickets
beavers and bartnik we're all sitting
there going I think that might have been
the greatest sporting event I went to
obviously seeing the Patriots when the
Super Bowl was bigger but the level of
excitement like I just never been never
been to anything like that and if you
ever get a [ __ ] chance that is
definitely one worth stub hobbing oh the
college gift [ __ ] the students were
crazy and they had all these funny
chants and I'm sure everybody's gonna
say all they stole this from you they
stole this from this guy and blah blah
blah blah blah I don't [ __ ] know but
it was making me laugh you don't want
anyone introducing the UNC players I'll
just use my name they just say yeah
playing [ __ ] point guard number
[ __ ] zero bill burr and then the
whole student section just goes hi bill
you suck and they just did it through
the whole thing it was childish
it was [ __ ] hilarious they started
chanting I couldn't tell what they were
chanting and then I gradually figured it
out it was crazy towel guy I was like
crazy what the [ __ ] are they saying
crazy what and people start turning
around looking at us and then I realize
they look and be honest we look up and
all of a sudden this [ __ ] old guy
gets up starts whipping this towel
around his head there's old [ __ ]
lunatic I'm like I guess that's I guess
that's the crazy towel guy right so it's
going back and forth back and forth all
these crazy chance you let your whole
team down all of this [ __ ] the next
thing you know it's like halftime we're
sitting there going like dude what the
[ __ ] was that that was 20 minutes of
basketball that felt like a minute my
ears were ringing like I'd gone to a
concert and there's still another half
to play then all of a sudden this asian
lady comes out this asian coming out on
like a [ __ ] three-story unicycle and
she's doing that act where you [ __ ]
you flip the saucer onto your head okay
which I had seen before I've seen the
act done before I never seen it live but
was [ __ ] hilarious mercy and bartnik
had never seen that that's saying I
wasn't blown away I was definitely blown
away so she she goes to like flip it on
a head now first of all you know when
you stop on
you cycle he can't just stop you got to
do that front back front back front back
doing now she's doing that with one foot
on the [ __ ] pedal she's got a goddamn
soup bowl I won over the end of her feet
on her toes you know your feet a lot of
people notice your toes right so
everybody's sitting there right she
[ __ ] flips it it does like a triple
Lindy and lands on the top of her head
and everybody's just like oh yeah right
so then she [ __ ] with the things
still on her [ __ ] head the little
soup kitchen cup there right she rides
down to another the other corner of the
basketball court
now she puts two down now first he
starts going no way no [ __ ] way no
[ __ ] way
right there Fred it [ __ ] lands whole
crowd oh then she goes to do three so
she's got one up right the others upside
down the others up right just going like
right up her [ __ ] shin and she
[ __ ] landed that and virzi stood up
you ever see what black people go to
church and what they call it catching
the Holy Ghost
that's what looked like happened to Paul
virzi everybody was sitting down virzi
stood up and applauded I'm [ __ ] dying
laughing she goes to four bulls
everybody's like no [ __ ] four Bulls go
in the air land right on ahead one two
three four oh crap right then she goes
down her closing bit not one not two not
three or four she puts five [ __ ] soup
bowls it's all the way up to her knee
okay oh I forgot to tell you this fit
this guy's like flipping the Bulls so he
flipped went to her and he [ __ ] threw
it too short she dropped it and I was
going on [ __ ] he just jinxed her he just
[ __ ] with their rhythm it's like
calling a timeout to ice to kick her so
she's got five flips him up in the
[ __ ] air one two three four and the
fifth one bounced off her head ever he's
like there's no Santa Claus right you
know what she said
she said [ __ ] that set him up again
right teaching these kids
he's [ __ ] Millennials or whatever the
[ __ ] he called these kids nowadays these
kids who grew up with knee pads elbow
pads and helmets when they rode bicycles
their playdates they they weren't a left
alone in the company of adults that no
one really knew who they were these
these kids were sheltered they don't
know how to make a comeback these kids
get drunk they call uber right
everything's just set up for so they
don't know how to [ __ ] pull
themselves off the mat you know well let
me tell you something this lady on this
one [ __ ] tired bicycle she showed
them how cuz she said hey [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] that you throw me five
more she sent him up again right flip
them in the air landed all five [ __ ]
place goes nuts just as loud as the
goddamn almost as loud as the [ __ ]
game there was no break there was no
break in the excitement that [ __ ]
ends we're looking gone what the [ __ ]
did we just say and out comes Coach K
[ __ ] Duke and UNC and it gets loud
again more chanting more singing more
[ __ ] scream and came all the way down
Duke finally put the game away with like
a [ __ ] minute left with a couple of
foul shots and I would just sat there in
the last few seconds when I knew that
Duke was gonna win and I just looked in
looked around looked at everything I
could look at try to make his enough
mental pictures as I could to take it in
because I knew I was just like I don't
know if I'll ever get back to seeing one
of these again but I don't know if that
didn't sell you I'd [ __ ] beat you got
to do it that is dude [ __ ] Madison
Square Garden it's a Mecca [ __ ] that
place you can go down there and see the
[ __ ] Ice Capades
save your money go on StubHub all right
going stuff up and and just get yourself
some tickets and go there you will not
be disappointed and you got to go while
Coach K is still there who by the way I
believe tomorrow the 13th is his 70th
birthday how great does that guy look
[ __ ] guy looks like he's like maybe a
year younger two years older than me I
don't know who would have thought
without with a
a job that's stressful you could still
look that good you know anyways let me
read a little bit of advertising there
we go oh dollar shave club everybody
dollar shave club all right you know
something there's no reason to use cheap
disposable rate to use it a cheap
disposable razor or pay a ridiculously
high price for some gimmicky thing
that's got a laser pointer with 17
blades make this choice and joint Dollar
Shave Club before Dollar Shave Club
it was either save money and get a
painful shape from a disposable like the
ones that give away for free at the gym
which felt like shaving with a piece of
[ __ ] glass or you paid a fortune for
the latest gimmicky shave breakthrough
that you didn't need that had like a
[ __ ] laser chin detector or 17 blades
or whatever Dollar Shave Club is the
best of both words world's a premium
shade and a disposable price get it
close smooth shave every time and you
can't you can't beat the convenience or
the price of the club if you haven't
tried to all the shave club yet you're
missing out it's an amazing shape god
they write so much [ __ ] copy
there's no smarter choice and right now
they give it away oh I'm on trial for
only I need that raises for only $1 with
free shipping and after that it's just a
few bucks a month it's no long-term
commitment no hidden fees you can cancel
another [ __ ] you want mm-hmm
get your $1 trial at dollarshaveclub.com
/ / that's dollarshaveclub.com / / oh
you know some of our fate one of my
favorites here look who's back it's all
zip are you hiring
why are you do you know where to post
your job to find the best candidates you
son of a [ __ ] posting your jobs in one
place isn't enough to find high-quality
candidates you might as well walk down
the street and say hey buddy buddy do
you want a job no sorry right might as
well do it that way
that make any sense probably didn't I'm
just saying you know people use this
[ __ ] you're gonna be behind the 8-ball
this is why I stick to the copy posting
your job once one place isn't enough to
find quality candidates if you want to
find the
perfect hire you need to post your job
on all the top job sites and now you can
with zip comm you can post your job to
200 plus job sites including social
media like Facebook and Twitter all with
a single click find the candidates in
any city or industry nationwide just
post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll in to zip recruit is
easy to use interface no juggling emails
or calls to your office quickly screen
candidates radom look at our tits
we'll give her a shot and hire the right
person fast find out today why zip it's
been used by Fortune 100 companies and
thousands of small and medium-sized
businesses right now my listeners could
post a job on sip recruiter for free by
going to sip recruiter comm / / that sip
recruiter comm / / one more time try it
for free and go to zip rudakov / / m vm
t watches also known as movement watches
pronounced movement was founded on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank with over 1 million watches sold to
customers in a hundred sixty countries
around the [ __ ] world movement
watches has solidified itself as one of
the fastest growing watches companies
and let me tell you the owners of this
company well their personalized have
suffered broken marriages broken dreams
but god damn it they're getting you
these [ __ ] watches the company
started by two broke college kids they
didn't have any money and then somehow
they started a company i've never
understood that detail wanted to wear
stylish watches but they couldn't afford
it so they started their own watch
company this definitely sounds like an
Ivy League think you know when I didn't
have a [ __ ] watch and I didn't have
any money I just didn't wear a watch I
didn't start a [ __ ] watch company
these Kennedys I was ok how is this like
how you started build a file shut up
movement watches start at just $95 the
department's at a department store
you're looking at four to five hundred
bucks moving watches ok basically they
got a great watch it's not in a
department store so they can cut out all
this [ __ ] money you know they start
at 95
bucks the great people won't know that
there it's a piece of [ __ ] you know it's
not a piece of [ __ ] but they won't know
that it's not like a [ __ ] you know I
don't get out of this it's a nice watch
all right but it doesn't cost a lot of
money okay
over 1 million watches sold over hundred
sixty countries get 50% off today with
free shipping with free returns by going
to movement watches dot-com / / this
watch has a really clean design
seriously
alright you get a bunch of compliments
whenever you put it on okay even if it's
sitting on oh my god is that that's a
really nice quality watch don't touch it
that was the time to step up your game
go-to movement watches comm / verb join
the movement oh mercifully this is the
last one o stamps common everybody you
know I use stamps calm whenever I send
out my posters of my my sports bras
whatever the [ __ ] I'm selling at the end
of shows to [ __ ] myself out you know
when I was like you know what I'm gonna
go out here and make a little bit of
extra cash you know shake some hands
when every 15 is gonna [ __ ] feel like
they just got out of a sauna postage
rates have gone up again
that means trips to the post is a post
office are even an even bigger hassle
man it's so crowded but thanks to stamps
calm you don't have to worry about that
just use stamps calm to automatically
calculate and print the correct amount
of postage for every letter or package
is sent
stamps.com brings you all the service of
the post office right to your fingertips
will even send you a digital scale
automatically calculate the exact post
is they do everything but send a [ __ ]
robot in there to do it for you
stamps.com will even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs
they give you postage discounts you
can't get at the post office including
three cents off every first-class stamp
right now use my code bir for this
special offer four week trial includes
postage in a digital scale why would the
post office do that three cents off
going to their business they must have a
cut of stamps don't come I have no idea
four week trial includes a postage
includes postage and a digital scale
scale go to stamps comm click on the
microphone atop the homepage and type in
bar that stamps commenter birth
and sign up today stamps.com you'll
never have to go to the goddamn post
office again alright
and with that you know this thing is
just really not responding the way it
used to is it time for a new laptop
alright
do I have anything else hey what is all
this attacking on fake news lately I
don't understand it why is the
government getting so mad at fake news
it's so [ __ ] hilarious watching them
get ups and getting upset about that hey
don't read their fake news read our fake
news read our version of the [ __ ]
it's all fake [ __ ] news have you ever
got into a car accident a little fender
bender and the cop shows up are you a
police officer have you ever heard two
people tell you the exact same story
this [ __ ] guy came out of [ __ ]
nowhere then he go over the other guy
what happened I came out of [ __ ]
nowhere I wasn't even looking never
happens it's all fake news it's it's all
opinions right for the most part other
than you know somebody dies this guy is
[ __ ] dead okay you can agree on that
how he died why died who's responsible
not Jesus Christ bill we get it okay
that's all I'm saying
it's all that's all really saying here
all right let's get to well let's get to
the content here to read some some of
you letters here all right Yoko Ono
makes Julian Lennon by letters he wrote
to his dad and auction all right bill is
there a worse woman in history I hate to
be hacky I know the Beatles days were
numbered it wasn't just her but it
didn't help
yeah but at the end of the day John
chose her this is what happened
something happened between John and his
mom she died or she [ __ ] I don't know
she beat him with a wooden spoon I
forget how the [ __ ] story went all
right but whatever she did or if she
died it's not her fault it left him with
the psychological makeup to be
susceptible to not trying to just find a
mate he also wanted a mom and all she
had to do was make some cookies
all right make him some cookies on his
[ __ ] birthday whatever the [ __ ] he
wanted and then that was it this guy was
done you know I think he would you know
if he lived they somewhere in his
mid-forties he just would have been like
all right you know what what the [ __ ]
was that maybe he would've got out maybe
maybe he liked it I have no idea but
anyways let's continue he said then
there's the video will you call her out
for screeching like a maniac during a
powerful moment in history now she won't
give her husband's son some paper he
gave his dad 20 years earlier this story
might be a bit old but it doesn't seem
to make but it doesn't make it any less
true
I watched the clip what it is was she
auctioned off a bunch of his [ __ ] he's
warning this she's not making him pay
for it she sold it and Julian wants to
get it back but because Yoko sold it he
has to buy it back now I in defense of
her what I would say is the cash cow
died it's not like Yoko could go out and
[ __ ] sell take records like a Beale
so all of a sudden she's going like holy
[ __ ] how am I still gonna be able to
live in the Dakota so she starts selling
all his [ __ ] or maybe her husband died
she wanted to [ __ ] move on didn't
want to look at all his old [ __ ] you
know what I mean I have no idea but yeah
I watched a little of that video Julian
definitely goes hard on her and says
that he thinks she's extremely
manipulative and that she knew what the
[ __ ] she was doing from day one and I
can't remember if that's actually his
mother I don't know how is he related
that they do you know the [ __ ] knows I I
don't know
is there a worst woman in history yeah
there's way worse women those women that
ran empires and had people killed you
know for whatever [ __ ] reason you
know the the the story of Scarface the
second one the one that Pacino did was
based on a you know there was the
original movie but the story
that they used in in the the second one
were based on a drug-dealer of that time
who actually was a woman so I mean yeah
I would say she was worse you know
having people shot in the [ __ ] Street
is probably worse than selling some
postcards but you know it's all up to
interpretation you know this is the new
me the new meditating bill the more
relaxed bill who's undoing the [ __ ]
knots of anxiety in his mind not say
enough about [ __ ] meditating now that
I'm not trying to like get good at it
I'm just trying to do it I don't flip
out to the level I used to like I think
you know say like 10 is the worst
flipping out I think I used to walk
around just walk around on a good day I
was already out of six compared to how
most people are when they're just like
totally chilling out so it was a very
quick and easy trip up to 10 now I feel
like I walk around it like a three I
feel like I've cut it in half so now
when I flip out I kind of just go to six
which is still totally unacceptable for
most social situations I still flip out
and people look over their shoulder
startled but not with the level of what
the [ __ ] you know what I mean reminds me
this time I saw I was on like a highway
eight or something interstate 8 I think
I was in Arizona or New Mexico I don't
where the [ __ ] I was it and there's bull
it's somehow gotten free I mean I was in
the middle of [ __ ] nowhere I was and
there was two Cowboys right on horses
and these are Cowboys they're trying to
[ __ ] rope a goddamn bull which I
don't know if you can do I don't want
the [ __ ] they were doing so one of
them's trying to distract the bull is
the other one is on a horse that is
sneaking up behind it and of course is
stinking up the way horses sneak up in a
[ __ ] cartoon and this bull at the
last second figured it out and he
[ __ ] turned around you know that look
Bruce Willis always does when he looks
over his shoulder and die hard
it's the same thing except it was a
[ __ ] bull that's the look that people
when I would lose my [ __ ] prior to
meditate I would get that look everyone
would [ __ ] turn around like you know
a skyscraper was on fire and it was just
some [ __ ] balding redhead flipping
out because he couldn't figure out the
new operating system on his on his
smartphone completely unacceptable
so my temper has really reduced and I'm
telling you if I can just not [ __ ] do
I just made this statement out loud like
I'm my daughter's not gonna see me flip
it out you know I'm not saying I won't
every way which is [ __ ] drawn on the
wall at some point but she's not gonna
see me yelling at computers it's just
not gonna happen okay and I say it out
loud when I say it out loud that means
it happens right
I hope so anyways I'm trying [ __ ] you
guys I'm trying anytime I talk about
this to him I stand up back then I'm
gonna try to fix my temper people just
start laughing they laugh at a point
they make me feel bad
alright Italy and the European Union
hey there Capitol Hill bill I'm just uh
bill yes I'm only a bill and I'm sitting
here on Capitol Hill and okay I'm a
political science professor from a
school I won't name to keep with your
policy of not naming names I having
studied and taught the subject it's fair
to say I look at what goes on today from
a much wider scope wider scope than who
me I would hope so I would hope so wider
than me all right and that's not
something that is only exclusive to
receiving a master's in political
science could you pat yourself on the
back anymore sir did your elbow patch
fly off your [ __ ] left arm of your
sport coat when you reached back to that
is all I love this guy and that's not
only something that is only exclusive to
receiving a master's in political
science this guy should be wearing a
scarf with a nice breeze going anyone
can read souls in Eason thank you for
[ __ ] sound spelling that for me
and others who have honestly captured an
important perspective of history and
have a much clearer understanding of how
and why governments and socialites have
evolved through history anyways there is
one thing that is flown under the radar
now that I've gotten my resume out of
the way there's one thing has flown
under the radar and I think it should
scare the [ __ ] out of most European
countries all right let me start by
saying in short that the European Union
parenthesis which in my opinion is run
by fascists with self-interest I just
stop here and say this is the most
well-written [ __ ] email I've ever
received on the podcast this is
incredible
let me start by saying in short that the
European Union which my opinion is run
by fascists was self-interest tried to
take control of Italy's army for the
sake of your time I will spoil the
ending Italy did not vote to allow the
EU to take over that moved by the EU
alarmed some of my peers who I in 20
plus years of knowing them have not seen
them alarmed by anything in terms of
government in the scheme of things a
banking institution openly financing
legislation that is trying to gain
control of a foreign country's foreign
governments military is for the lack of
a better term really really ballsy why
don't I feel like I've missed some
information here ok so the European
Union tried to take over italy's army
okay I see that Italy did not vote to
allow the EU to take over so when you
join the European Union they took take
over your army is that what you're
saying ok so that move by the EU alarmed
some of my peers what move oh trying to
take over you ok you jump it back and
forth here I can't tell what you're
talking about okay take control of
Italy's army okay so them trying to take
control of their army yeah how would you
do that ok the idea that it just
finished us the idea that certain
globalist groups are trying to take
control
world is not an incredible idea among
people who are versed in political
economics or conspiracy theorists like
myself but you know something me they
just go what do you got your [ __ ] tan
hat on and you if you just started
saying what the [ __ ] you just said you
probably run into the same problem like
you just I just said it was the best
written email ever and I got lost in it
because I'm too [ __ ] stupid
understand what you're talking about so
it's got to be hard man you just got to
hang out with people with the [ __ ]
elbow patches on their sport coats right
anyways the idea that certain globalist
groups are trying to take control of the
world is not an incredible idea among
people who are versed in political
economics I've heard you talk about
stuff like this in the context of a
conspiracy and so other than this
possibly possibly being interesting to
you it's also too it's also affirm that
you are not out of your mind I attached
an article if you'd like to read further
I absolutely would look at this how
about that everybody all you [ __ ] and I
got a ten hat on tinfoil hat on whatever
the [ __ ] that means half of you say that
you don't even know what it means
you got your tinfoil hat on you know I
don't know what the [ __ ] it means what
is that is that like my antenna if I'm
doing some sort of pirate radio tinfoil
hat meaning I know what it means means
you're out of your [ __ ] mind but how
did it come about a tinfoil hat is made
from one or more sheets of aluminum foil
or a piece of conventional headgear
lined with foil worn in the belief or
hope that it shields the brain from
threats such as electromagnetic fields
mind control and minor E oh I see I see
well you know that's some MacGyver [ __ ]
I can go with that might set a bad thing
anyway so well where the [ __ ] was a I've
attached I wouldn't know it actually
it's released how long is this though so
something I can read you know I'll read
about this and I'll give you my
uninformed opinion my moronic opinion on
the next podcast how about that does
that work for you does that grab you
alright fat guys turns out to not be fat
Billy Twinkle Bose this guy told was
told by a doctor his whole life that he
was fat yeah this huge frontal thing on
going on that turned out to not be a
giant belly but a 130 pound tumor how
many people do you know will start using
the tumor defense I actually looked this
[ __ ] thing up the guy is fat he's
very fat even after the [ __ ] tumor I
mean like he's laying in bed and he has
it's like he has an inner tube of fat
going around I think that's what his
neck is this guy's so [ __ ] fat he had
a 130-pound tumor and he just thought it
was part of his love-handle he is fat
I'm glad they got it out of that Jesus
how do you kill how do you get that out
of there 130 pounds how the [ __ ] do you
I mean you got to take it out in
sections ten pounds at a time you need
to make thirteen [ __ ] incisions Jesus
Christ and just throwing it over your
shoulder hitting the ground like a
[ __ ] bowling ball Jesus Christ you
know I knew a guy dad you know
everybody's talking about probiotics and
they talk about the bacteria in your gut
that it'll you know there's bacteria in
your gut that's supposed to be there
they try to scare your [ __ ] out of you
but it's supposed to be there it's there
for when you die and it begins the
decomposing process provided you're not
full of [ __ ] preservatives and you
just decompose because you're not
important and you just become part of
the earth again but we stickups
ourselves in these fancy [ __ ] boxes
because we think we're too good to be
warm food for whatever [ __ ] reason
but anyways alcohol eats away at the
good [ __ ] the good bacteria that you
need while you're alive like you're
supposed to be balanced and you're
supposed to have more the good bacteria
because if you have more the bad
bacteria you can actually you know your
own [ __ ] way you're beginning to
decompose while you're still alive or in
a short way you're starting to die this
is the way this guy explained it to me
so he started getting to distend
belly they didn't know what the [ __ ] was
going on and he wouldn't go to the
doctor and then finally he found out you
know somebody said maybe you got a
tapeworm and that freaked him the [ __ ]
out they could have been something alive
in him and he went to the doctor and
then they found out that that's what it
was and they gave him some medicine
and you know and he had this [ __ ] it all
out that's basically what happens so I
don't know even then I always buy the
Greek yogurt and it goes bad I always
think like hey I'll slam a couple of
scotches in the next morning I'll have
two spoonfuls of [ __ ] Greek yogurt
yogurt I'll be fine
I was happy in the life insurance they
said a nice [ __ ] easy you know heart
rhythm I was also meditating when they
did it you know I was being totally
present I was listening to the sounds of
the room I slowed my pretty think I
tricked those [ __ ] but I also had the
Bruins game on in the background so I
was trying not to react to what the [ __ ]
was going on because we left this
[ __ ] kunti goal at the end of the
second period with like one second left
all right crazy Saddam story crazy all
right hey Bill thought I'd brighten your
day with this crazy account of what went
down in Iraq when Saddam took power
basically they gathered all government
officials in one room the current
military leader gets brought out on
stage he clearly he's clearly been
beaten he admits to having committed
treason but clearly he hasn't they then
start calling out officials one at a
time so everyone was scared shitless
that they'd be called out and marched
out into a courtyard with the others
then after half of them were gone the
remaining officials were all taken out
to the courtyard and told that if they
didn't shoot the traitors they and their
families would be killed that way they
all had blood on their hands insane
here's the whole account and to think
the u.s. still did business with Saddam
with them after that haha dude as far as
I know we kind of put that guy in over
there you know and we were cool with the
guy until he [ __ ] tried to go around
us and start selling oil to other I
don't know what the [ __ ] he did we you
know you know I mean Saddam Hussein
to the United States he was like one of
those [ __ ] first-round draft choices
that that's a bust he was a bust for us
you know in a very promising college
career and you know he just he just
didn't have the passion actually he was
a very passionate guy he just wasn't
passionate in the wrong I don't know who
the [ __ ] knows
I mean it's all evil [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
just like the most base level evil cuz
they're not even trying to hide it but I
got to tell you when Trump was talking
to that [ __ ] guy there on from Fox
News Bill O'Reilly and Bill O'Reilly
give him [ __ ] that he was friends with
Putin Putin or whatever the [ __ ] his
name was and he goes the guy's like he's
a killer to have a [ __ ] standing
president go well look at this country
look what we've done my jaw hit the
[ __ ] ground like is he actually gonna
say this you can't say this everybody
knows it's true but you can't [ __ ]
say this no we only kill the bad people
the [ __ ] out here it's all [ __ ] evil
and that goes back to that fake news
that's why they need to take control the
fake news so they can spin it you know
what I mean the guy it came out of
[ __ ] nowhere the Saddam Hussein where
we had a green light he came out of
[ __ ] nowhere everybody does it
everybody does it you know what and I
[ __ ] do it too we're all spinning it
we're all spinning our own horse [ __ ] we
all think we're [ __ ] I'm not gonna speak
for you guys if I'm spinning my own
[ __ ] right this is my favorite video
anybody sent me in a long [ __ ] time
um oh by the way if you want to watch
that Saddam thing I'll post all these
videos I don't know if I want to watch
it that stuff I don't know I don't like
watching [ __ ] like that all right 100
nine-year-old guy smokes cigars and
drinks whiskey dear Billy deer farm
State bill I know you have a life
insurance policy test but I thought you
might want to see this this 109 year old
guy smoked cigars all day not saying
it's great for everyone but figured
you'd want to hear the title actually
marginalized this guy's life he's got a
great attitude he still drives he's the
oldest living World War two veteran
you'd really enjoy this he talks about
having a truck for a long time and they
show his old school TV
the giant dials he keeps it all because
it works and he likes it come to Boston
I [ __ ] love this guy he said at one
point he smokes 12 cigars a day he goes
I don't inhale so you inhale he goes you
get in trouble the bottom line is you
know whatever his genetics are this
works for him because I know if I smoke
12 a day at first why I couldn't
physically [ __ ] do it
but he and it's like a 79 look like a 78
or 79 Ford pickup truck he had an old
Square TV that still had the legs on it
from like the 70s he built his house in
like 1940 he still lives there he said I
like the [ __ ] that I have it still works
so I'm not buying more [ __ ] it's like
what I'm trying to do now get rid of all
this extra [ __ ] that I bought and I got
to tell you watching this guy watching
his life is the life that I'm slowly
moving towards it's the life that I want
after running around like a [ __ ]
lunatic reacting to everything for the
first [ __ ] you know forty something
years of my life you know I would like
to slow down a little bit as far as
being up I mean look I'm still I know
all you guys have worried that God God
he's gonna slow down he's not gonna be
[ __ ] fine I'm still gonna completely
[ __ ] up somebody do dumb [ __ ] I'm gonna
be fine but I don't have to be walking
or I basically walked around stuck in
fight-or-flight mode probably from the
age of eight till now and I don't know
it's a stupid it's not it's funny to
observe but it really wears on the
people around you and eventually it
[ __ ] wears you down and it's just
like the amount of [ __ ] time that I
have wasted arguing with people where
they're not gonna change their mind I'm
not gonna change my mind
I've just I've I'm done I'm past that
point my [ __ ] life and it feels
[ __ ] great I just have to believe
that I am I'm trying to do now when I
flip up cuz I know there's other angry
constant listen to this and you listen
to this because
I'm an angry [ __ ] - it probably makes
you feel better about yourself which is
why I love Bobby Knight thought you
watch Bobby Knight you know like oh my
god I'm a [ __ ] Saint this guy now
this guy's got a temper that day I'm
telling you right now yeah your wife
ever gives you [ __ ] for having a temper
it's like you think I got a temper just
cut to go you can be married to that and
I love Bobby Knight by the way so
anyways I just now like I don't know I
try to in the moment I just try to
[ __ ] like this is funny thing that
happens like when my daughter you know
needs a diaper changed it's like you
know you hear them farting and
everything so you're thinking like okay
that's definitely you know and you think
I'm without getting into the gross
details just think you hear the fart and
you think that's the gun sounding the
end of the game and then once you get
into it you realized that wasn't a gun
sounding the end of the game or even the
end of the half that was the sound of
the [ __ ] jets flying over the game
over the stadium right after the [ __ ]
national anthem and the games about
ready to begin
I had a left pad save yesterday blocker
cheese block saved my wall took it all
on my shirt and all that it's just like
it's [ __ ] unbelievable and whatever
that happens like a couple times I went
like Mia why did you tell me to come in
she's still going like she could tell
like there's any way for my wife to know
whether my daughter is done going to the
bathroom or not she's got no [ __ ]
idea and I apologized and I just
addressed that I was angry and I did I
did it two more [ __ ] times and now
now I got it down now I just say
something as I walk up to the changing
table at 3:00 or 4:00 in the morning and
I just basically say if she's not done
and you know this is not anybody's fault
this is just part of having a kid don't
flip out and I and I'll see how that
works for me tonight
that's just base I just before I just
kept it all in my head
and then it becomes like it isn't that's
it's sort of
sort of real but isn't I just find when
I say it out loud then I could [ __ ]
address it and so we'll see that but I
gotta tell you I actually [ __ ] really
enjoy changing diapers and everything we
gave my daughter our first bath ever
right in the kitchen sink old-school
style I'm sure we were supposed to have
like a [ __ ] hazmat suit team come in
and disinfect the sink and she's
supposed to wear a helmet and some scuba
gear but that's not our bringing her up
we're going we're going old school I've
been playing music for her and
everything got this exercise ball really
just kind of puts it asleep and I just
play music and she just totally chills
out the stuff that she's enjoyed so far
she likes Herbie Hancock I was playing
some Billy Cobham some of this [ __ ] I
just been listening to what else has she
been listen to some of the pop stuff she
really likes I think they just like
music in general they just kinda like
what the what is that and I don't know
that's getting at that point she's just
starting to be able to look around and
he kind of sit there going like I think
she's actually looking at me right now
then right as you make a guy contact
like a are you [ __ ] looking at me her
eyes just kind of drift away and look at
something else I'm like alright I guess
I'm still like an acid trip when she
looks at me but anyways we're having a
great time and even though I'm not
getting any sleep
it's totally [ __ ] worth it and it's
it's I'll tell you if you're if you're
an older dad it's not as [ __ ] hard
they try to say oh my god you're old and
gonna try to do this it's like yeah I'm
old and I have a house you know I'm not
some [ __ ] struggling 20-something you
don't I mean [ __ ] broke kids trying
to pay off student loans and then you
have a kid people in their 20s if they
complain about having a kid I yeah
without a doubt I'll listen to that but
if you're in your 30s and 40s yeah go go
[ __ ] yourself alright that's it okay
that's the podcast for for Monday once
again please check out Nick DiPaolo
special on seeso this Thursday
at 8 p.m. I'm telling you he's one of
the best of his generation and one of
the best of the last [ __ ] whatever
[ __ ] he started 30 years ago one of my
favorites and it's it's an honor to be
able to plug his special alright so
check it out your [ __ ] I'll check in on
you on Thursday